welcome to this video playing gender I
under five and five or six sets a good
score so I better not start losing now
okay the Hungarian defense to the to the
UM to the Italian game yeah it's
probably not so bad i have and i have no
knowledge whatsoever is this already not
so great actually one day if you can do
some kind of like EDC d90 for those kind
of things probably not just yet but not
far away from from working yeah probably
probably c3 is not writer I really never
looked at this opening I have no idea
hmm how bad is 95 you know so let's
complete complete development here yeah
he will take and play the fire probably
something like that
but it doesn't seem that he wants to
take ever this looks a lot like a
Spanish rule apes' opening and figures
be five that that could be had some rid
of baseline very easily imagine about
okay before I goes a five so that's no
move I want before against see form
still I can do see from there okay it's
not not a big problem c 4 B 4 a 5 is the
somewhat inconvenient for me OC form
yeah that's also good yeah we just
closed the Queen side and then the
attention shifts to the King side at
least I have some experience with this
tablet position from the black side
played a ton of of games with this kind
of setups Bishop to age six is what he
wants to do ah I should have tried to
prevent that unfortunately I didn't
hmm that's really no way to prevent it
now okay to not do that immediately see
just delaying it no it's putting the 911
which is not bad that is a very very
normal way to play okay f form I
definitely want the space in this
position
night only five here that is flex and
pride and joy I'd really want to want to
trade it okay and let's see how do I
make any headway it's very very funny
that I'm on the white side of this
played this kind of position to write
off with black pile up on the f are just
trying try and to do that night on g3
for some way to prove that
like to play G fire but it's not easy to
do
night to d3 bishop d 1 i'm trying to
regroup a little bit okay so if i take
can i take now not really it's not
helping me at all and that's difficult
five would be nice maybe I can get in d5
Bishop g-form still difficult to do
something attending attending a possible
g5 it very very difficult making any
headway
oh sorry for
let's just go back before was
unprotected it probably didn't matter
but it is something that I don't want to
want to allow more than once check my
idea is to try to trade with Bishop g4
but and so of course a very symmetrical
position so it is some quite likely that
i'm not going to win this simply because
of the closed nature of the position but
may okay i still have h5 gaining even
more space oh that's unexpected I 0915
at that sense really weird Queen h1
those kind of ideas
hmm not quite sure so I can give the
shaking here check
still not apparent that i have anything
it's it's so closed he's really limited
with this pollution but I know how
difficult it is to break it down it
really is difficult so invasion time
sometimes night f5 is the way to go
which I'd like to just try to take the
pawn or a five
925 somehow maybe check hmm it's got the
night tradin yeah it's this is a
question of time I just I would just
lose on time what was this was he
speculating on a pre move black resigns
yeah I mean okay this was an incorrect p
sacrifice by me but I mean hey I just
sit silly we went on time so you can do
this in 97 this is how I sometimes one
games with blank I just like or
passively sitting there all the time and
yeah it's not fun but you can play quick
moves and hope that the other guy is
simply screwing up white is clearly
better though something like this I know
it should be something it's a little bit
much with this active Queen having
invaded already I did this and this is
probably not helping this is what the
computer gives just goes here that this
is that yep the sacrifice simply
sacrifice him and it gets it gets to
zoosk lungs gets to Zeus Hwang Seon I'm
check getting getting getting in there
nie Dage form yeah that this is justice
is terrible but I didn't every time was
very difficult to really do something
something with her some sort of purpose
and in this little time but I got lucky
that hey that he he blundered this this
night back at the end okay well thanks
for watching